this is a production of cornell
university
yeah thanks uh thanks evan and
thanks to the department of natural
resources for giving me this uh
opportunity to go beyond my usual
repertoire of climate change slides uh
so i had to come up with a lot of new
stuff uh and this seminar is gonna
really reflect a lot of ideas that have
been
bouncing around my head for some time
and i'm curious to see
your reaction the first thing probably
is a little bit of uh
explanation about the title i'll try to
do that in terms of us being unique i
mean i do think you know just that so
many people would show up to a seminar
to hear about their own species being
dethroned
that's kind of unique about humans only
humans would do that
but you know that's not my objective
i'm really hoping that you know
when you leave here you'll you'll really
begin to recognize that there's a lot to
be gained
in appreciating what modern science is
revealing about our similarities with
other species that the differences are
really a matter of perspective
are existential angst about being alone
well we are not really so alone
we are not exempt from natural laws as
i'll emphasize quite a bit we are not
supernatural and i think many of us
academics i will argue when it comes to
our intelligence
actually have that tendency
and recognizing our limits might
actually help us tackle our biggest
environmental challenges
um so as was alluded to i mean i'm
coming up soon on my 25th anniversary of
doing climate change research
and you know in those years there's
really been two kind of broad surprises
that i've had
one is
the magnitude and pace of climate change
has been much more than i expected i
really in fact started by doing direct
effects of carbon dioxide on plants
thinking that the
climate change while it would come much
of it would come
after my career i didn't expect the arc
to be melting
when i still had
several years to go
the second surprise has been the
persistence of denial out there now i'm
not talking about
some valid debates about we have climate
change and should we or shouldn't we do
something about it but this this actual
persistence of denial that it even
exists
and now there's actually of course quite
a body of research there's a lot of body
research on climate change per se and
now there's a growing body of research
on why is there this denial
i'm only going to cover one little
thread and that's really going to focus
i think fairly relevant to this
department
on evolutionary biology the evolution of
the of the human mind um and how the
that the the con this constrains our
ability to tackle some of our global
environmental problems
okay the word illusion um i had thought
about the word delusion but that's got
kind of a psychotic twist and i decided
to be kind to our species and uh call it
illusion that means we don't
really have a take on reality
um
and
uh uh two two components of that
illusion i'll be emphasizing one is that
we are
exempt from natural laws which is kind
of a pre-enlightenment era problem but
i'll argue academics are as guilty as
anybody of still having a a major
fragment of that exemptionalism going on
and it has to do with our intelligence
um this idea that there's there's no
bound uh of our intelligence in terms of
the context of the evolution of our mind
that we can think our way out of
anything
an analogy that i often
think about myself when i
wrestle with this issue is thinking
about
let's look at birds and there they have
a special trait obviously ability to fly
imagine
eagles for example thinking well i'm at
the top of the i'm the best of all the
flyers
and taking that information instead of
sort of recognizing but still there are
limits because i have a certain wing
span etc thinking that you could fly
anywhere up to the heavens to see the
gods throughout the universe
that's actually i think what many humans
maybe many academics do with their
intelligence
the second illusion
related to the intelligence is that this
leads to a level of self-awareness and
there's of course a whole continuum of
self-awareness out there among species
and we're
just as we can
you know uh
surpass most other species on an iq test
in terms of levels of self-awareness
we are quite up there
but it could be at a point where it's
actually leading to an illusion taking
us away from reality
nicholas humphrey who's a theoretical
psychologist calls self-awareness a
magical mystery tour we staged for
ourselves
is this adaptive
or is that an illusion that does not
reflect ecological reality and that
constrains our capacity to adapt
so that's my explanation of the the
title
and i'm going to crank through my slides
i have a lot of stuff to go through
a lot on kind of these issues uh that i
mentioned sort of the evolution of the
human mind evolutionary theory etc to
begin with and uh
kind of last i'll get into its relevance
to climate change so first this is kind
of just an outline of what we'll be
talking about i'm going to talk about
our place on the tree of life
going from our great chain of being
hierarchy perspectives to modern
evolutionary theory
i'm going to go through a scientific
critique of the human exemptionalist
paradigm for those of you who aren't
familiar with that i have some papers
you could i could send your way after
this
but this is um
leads us to a couple of issues
um you know are complexity and
intelligence really unique and quote
royal traits or are they traits like any
other for example flight olfactory
ability
i'm going to talk about the mystical
mind how self-awareness in our our quote
free will
leads us to a notion of being unbounded
and exempt from natural laws we have a
little person between our ears really
a lot of us feel this way and i think
it's hard to divorce ourselves from that
and then finally our complexity
intelligence self-awareness for the
adaptive traits as i mentioned then i'm
going to talk about the evolutionary and
genetic constraints to human
consciousness
and then finally some realistic taking
this information and developing more
realistic approaches to addressing
climate change and other environmental
challenges
okay
here's aristotle's ladder of life
it has a uh what was really viewed at
the time of course there was there was
you know is a static
collection of species that range in
complexity of course microbial life was
not even uh known about this time
man of course is at the top
uh and notice that intelligence is is up
there at the top um as well not as
simply some trait that we have but it's
something that really takes us into the
spiritual realm
and i think that this is a place where
while today with modern ecology we
recognize that humans
interact with all these species and are
part of natural systems but i think we
often
get led into this notion that our
intelligence is something quite unique
and takes us to uh to the spiritual
this uh
aristotelian a notion got perfected
during the middle ages into this
so-called great chain of being
many many of the greatest thinkers of uh
for hundreds of years worked on the
great chain of being whose fits where
um
and there was a lot of uh uh
philosophers of the day
arguing for example that where we knew
man was at the top and there had to be a
god so therefore there must be angels
there's a lot of philosophical articles
about that
um saint thomas aquinas uh was uh took
part in uh some of this was in that era
and um
interesting to me having been raised a
catholic where i kind of uh you know
what the nuns told us is only humans
have a soul well saint thomas aquinas
didn't feel that way he felt actually
all living things had a soul but humans
had three souls and other species had
one or two so there's vegetative souls
sensitive soils which would be what we
call today sentient beings that might
have some level of intelligence but not
able with our special rational thought
and
this is kind of relates somewhat to an
area of philosophy today that's called
personal and non-personal minds a
personal mind is a mind that has not
only intelligence but a strong sense of
self-awareness whereas a non-personal
mind can be an intelligent being but has
a very weak or no sense of
self-awareness
this hierarchy got perfected look at
this list um we got royalty at the top
this is the you know work by very very
serious scholars in the middle ages who
fits where i like where you know actors
today are like such big shots right like
they're like royalty
they're just below beggars
of course now we can wonder you know
where would the
graduate students undergraduates
professors be but i'll leave it up to
you
this all got completely turned on its
head uh with darwin of course and of
course with a group like this we can can
we ever say enough about darwin
everything i ever work on he's already
done it
um
but he really did uh you know
revolutionize our thinking and in fact i
would argue uh what he came up with has
not really sunk in even among many
ecologists um today
uh really the main thing a
non-creationist tree of life not a
hierarchy
that all the species that we see today
have gone through the filter of natural
selection in sort of an equal fashion
they've been carrying on their genes for
at least some time
and some of them have been carrying on
those genes for billions of years
whereas other species have been carrying
on those genes like ourselves for maybe
a hundred thousand two hundred three
hundred thousand years something like
that but that we've all uh gone through
that that same filter
there was a continuity uh evolutionary
continuity
that
the difference in intelligence between
uh creatures was not a difference in
kind but a difference in degree
our own whitaker the whitaker room over
in uh course in mud many of you are
probably familiar with
he was one of the
leading
ecologists who worked on the five
kingdom evolutionary tree of life
perfecting what we know about evolution
primarily from the fossil record
microscopy
dividing
single celled organisms into prokaryotes
without a nucleus and eukaryotes
protozoa here
with the nucleus and nutritional studies
notice how this is dominated by
multicellular life
and humans still get up there somewhere
near the top probably the top of the
animals right
and gives you a perspective of there is
microbial life is now encompassed
well then along in the 1980s came a
fellow named carl woes who really
kicked us once again on this whole
evolutionary tree of life thing and
brought us into the molecular age and
molecular genetics age and turned much
of this on its head by
evaluating the molecular genetics of
even just the bacterial branch he found
if the if the yardstick of what is a
kingdom is the difference between a
human
and a mushroom
if that's the yardstick we're going to
use then within the bacterial branch
alone there had to be at least a dozen
different kingdoms
and he in fact discovered an entire new
uh domain of life the archaea
he was battled by many evolutionary
biologists who were primarily fossil
hunters and this didn't sit too well
because
his
his results really show that document
very clearly how much of life on our
planet has been microbial
but he made a major stamp almost as
dramatic as darwin's i would argue
here's the new evolutionary tree it
shows up in campbell's biology book
today it's making it into all the
textbooks
this is really
um
talking about perspective
um here's three kingdoms of the old five
kingdom tree the fungi animals and
plants right there
and this gives you definitely a
different perspective of a few things
first of all this new tree is really
based on the distances between these
things really reflect evolutionary time
i'm all of this life is microbial
much of the five kingdom tree and much
of our talk about evolution in the past
is based on the it's an eye of the
beholder
view of the world and how things work
multicellular life
also when you think about this i'm going
to be talking in a moment about
intelligence as an adaptable trait
you can see based on evolutionary time
how how it's been really within the
flick of an eye how long we've been here
and how long intelligence as a trait has
been around
and so it really has not been well
tested
but we still think but yeah yeah yeah
but we're you know but we win the iq
test we're more complex than everything
and etc
but uh you know
evolutionary biologists have been you
know trying to bring home to people for
many years this is some something out of
stephen j gold's book some years ago
talking about that complexity does not
equal progress as evolution goes
evolution can actually move in either
direction but it's clearly bound by the
left wall of minimal complexity the
upper panel is looking at pre-cambrian
time
and
the bottom panel is looking at today's
distribution of species in sort of a
cartoon fashion
as the number and kinds of species have
increased over time the right tail has
obviously developed some things spill
out into that tail but things can also
go the other way but they can't go
against that left wall
so the numbers and frequency of the
simplest forms have increased but we've
also developed a tail
the small number of species forming the
tail do not indicate an evolutionary
sequence of progress just the inevitable
consequence of the laws of probability
if we with all of our brilliance
set forth the nuclear holocaust and we
wiped out that tail
it would grow back
it would not be any of the same species
we know today intelligence might never
show up again
that could be just a happenstance of
what the conditions were during
that early period but that's something
to kind of keep in mind about
complexity
and
that sort of thing
but aren't humans truly unique in
complexity intelligence yes we win the
iq test and we're very complex
but
protozoa here much of our genetics much
of our genetic complexity in our own
bodies in all living things is really
wrapped up
you know we share with the protozoa much
of
earth life's complexity was worked out
in those first two or three billion
years it has to do with cellular biology
some of you may know about darwin's last
book a 300-page treatise on earthworms
and their importance to cycling uh
recycling and geology
in there he devoted 50 pages of 300
pages of his last book to earthworm
intelligence
um now i was looking for a human that
you know would be complex i was looking
for mona lisa or something and i don't
know i came up with penelope cruz
uh
i mean i've always thought i've never
met her but i
i would think of her as being a very
complicated woman she looks very
complicated
but but look at giuseppe
i mean what's going on in that mind
um you know i'm joking around but you
know what i want to point out is that
complexity again is a matter of degree
um intelligence oh yes the smartest man
that ever lives some would say certainly
one of the most brilliant people of the
20th century
einstein but when einstein was about
you know until he was about two and a
half years old he probably would flunk
well he would he would not do as well in
an iq test as that monkey or most
primates
in fact until he was age five or seven
he probably didn't not have the same
level of self-awareness as an adult
chimpanzee
so it's kind of age dependent
but
but certainly we do i'm not arguing that
we we don't have
you know some amazing abilities with
abstract thought
so now i want to go through and talk
about complexity and intelligence and
each of these topics i've got on this
list are worth the seminar on themselves
i'm just going to run through
some things that actually have come to
light really in my career
one of the first is
the human genome project now when i was
younger
the thought was the estimates for the
human genome were 50 000 to 140 000
genes we had to be the most of course
with most complicated creatures we had
to have the most genes it turns out we
had thirty thousand
um which is you know uh good news it's
about thirty percent more than a
nematode
but
it's about thirty percent less than a
tomato
uh so that kind of blows that theory of
course i know the geneticists out there
going what about spliced genes what
about we've gone beyond one gene one
protein there's we've come up with our
explanations for why you know this
doesn't hold anymore this isn't a good
the only indicator of complexity but
just to point out a few things that have
changed
our genetic makeup we have found is not
that unique we knew we were closely
related to the chimpanzees and other
primates but we didn't know that 99 of
our genes are similar to chimpanzees
and then of course immediately the
thought was when we found this out oh
yeah so that's all that all has to do
with brain power i one percent more
genes going into our amazing brain power
it turns out that many of those genes
have to do with larynx development
and in fact our frontal lobes while the
average brain size of humans is is
larger than most primates the frontal
lobe which is
in the uh brain scientists here that's
where rational thought comes from is
about the same as many primates
the neurochemicals associated with
emotional feelings and behavior are also
observed in many species we previously
assumed functioned instinctively
so oxytocin which is comes we can detect
in humans during mother daughter mother
child bonding shows up in other species
serotonin dopamine all kinds of
emotional
neural chemicals show up in other
species so if they're instinctive then
we're instinctive too or or else they
are much more like us than we thought
many social animals have sophisticated
language skills and i imagine this group
would follow some of the news about that
everything from prairie dogs to dolphins
to of course primates and they were
learning more about body language and
that sort of thing
abstract thought does not require
language for some research on pre-verbal
infants as well as some animals
several
other species have surprising levels of
self-awareness the one that kind of
really got to me is a fairly recent
report about dolphins
who in their first year of life named
themselves come up with a name for
themselves
and not only that but but uh others of
their species who might leave them for
some years and come back can remember
their names which is beyond what many
humans can do
uh
and the other thing is uh there have
been conversations as we're cracking the
code of dolphin dialogue
there's been conversations between
dolphins where they are naming another
you know the name of another of their
species is being brought up
many other species use tools in
sophisticated ways and this goes way
beyond primates particularly bird
species
and size doesn't matter when it comes to
brains
particularly bird brains
pigeons is a recent study showing
pigeons have numerical
capacity up to the scale of many
primates
so
and this is actually the modern genetic
sort of way of the correct sort of way
phylogenetically to
describe our our place um within our
closest relatives and you see we aren't
really above the rest
um
and why don't we really celebrate this
kinship um i'm not sure um
i think that's one thing i would like to
sort of bring out in this discussion
today is is talk about that how really
um instead of thinking of ourselves
about being above everybody else
recognizing the kinship and yet of
course
recognizing our unique capacity
is important darwin had some thoughts on
this
he saw this coming
and animals who have we have made our
slaves we do not like to treat as equals
it's not convenient
okay continuing with our notion of
superiority science versus the mystical
mind the spiritual mind the unbounded
intelligence
so i've given while we have superior
intelligence it's not a royal trait
except in our own minds
like other traits
dogs have a have the ability for to pick
up certain sense ten thousand times on
what humans can do
there is a continuum of ability among
species with intelligence and excelling
at one single trait does not guarantee
evolutionary success
our intelligence is also constrained by
the context of its evolution
and i'm going to have some slides to
follow which are going to bring this
into gear in particular to climate
change how the context of what the world
was like the climate was like as our
minds evolved affects our ability to
deal with climate change
the trade as i mentioned when i was
showing the new tree of life is a very
recent introduction
and whether the adapter or the long haul
has not been established
in fact it may be maladaptive
as it may lead to an illusion of
separateness from other species that we
know is not true based on what we know
about ecology an illusion of unbounded
and unbiased
mental capacity
that uh that self-awareness issue can
really become
a bit of a trap for ourselves
and
lead us into a place where we we can't
really can't
get out of it
is it the ultimate achievement of
intellect our self-awareness or source
of delusion what did the smartest man in
the world have to say about that
we experience ourselves our thoughts and
feelings as something separate from the
rest a kind of optical delusion of
consciousness the delusion is a kind of
prison for us restricting us to our
personal desires into affection for a
few persons nearest to us
okay
now i'm going to turn my attention to
getting into a little more details about
the context of our evolution and how
this might affect our response to
climate change
the human mind evolved primarily to
respond to local conditions it was it's
a natural selection it came from a brain
an organ it didn't come from the spirits
above it's not different than
the ability of birds and their wings to
fly
it's it's constrained by what our how
our brain evolved and that brain evolved
in response to natural selection which
was not dealing with abstract global
challenges on the other side of the
planet local challenges and so here i
think climate change among environmental
problems
is uniquely
difficult to deal with compared to for
example fracking or local water
pollution problem
which are can be very local
on the other hand
the
many people are afraid of the
the reaction to climate change that is a
policy for example that might affect
their local economy
in other words a gas tax which is going
to make their life their local
environment more difficult
so there's this kind of two-pronged
issue where people many people are more
afraid of the local consequences of a
policy reaction to climate change than
they are to some abstract global
threat
like all products of evolution
human consciousness is actually
pragmatic in nature
while capable of abstract thought our
minds are more interested in the
concrete
i suppose at a place like cornell you do
tend to find more people that are
you know quite fascinated with the
abstract uh
i'm i'm there
um
but but really if you look at the human
species at large uh we're much more
interested in what works not why it
works and and that really is the
consequence again of evolving the mind
evolving through natural selection
you know one thing our intellect has
done is create complex social structures
in part many
uh there's one school of thought that in
part our complex social structures
whether it be governments or religions
are a response to the anxiety of this
sense of agency and choice that we have
this sense of self-determination
so that
instead of having to make all these
choices ourselves we let the group that
we belong to make some of those choices
for us
it could be everything from going to war
to not doing anything about climate
change or could be on the positive side
um so our social structures can work for
us or against us but they can actually
in many cases limit our
capacity for choice many uh recent
climate change studies have shown some
surveys have shown
that
even shown solid evidence of climate
change right in their neighborhood
depending on the social group people are
with they may or may not believe in
climate change
our minds evolved over a long period
when there were very few humans on the
planet and abundant resources over a
hundred thousand more years homo sapiens
have been around and during almost all
of that time into the last couple
hundred years
the pressure on our resources
was not like it is today so it was quite
our minds involved in a time when we
could go out and get what we needed from
the resources around us of course
there's some local issues some local
times when uh for example jared diamond
in his book collapse talks about
things can still locally become
restrictive but in general
we we have that sort of issue to get
around we now are in on a planet where
um we have many more people
in our minds involved in a period of
climate stability compared to current
and projected climate change
so now i've got a few slides to kind of
go through emphasize a few of those
things the thing about human population
and i know it's not very clear from the
back but you don't need to see the
details really this graph in the upper
right this is showing
going back to 10 000 bc
showing the number of humans on the
planet
and actually of course you know homo
sapiens has been around another at least
another 80 90 000 years depending on
the data you look at but you know almost
no humans no humans during all that
evolution of our minds
it's only been in the very recent past
that we've had this skyrocketing in
population
so from this you can see why in our
brains have not really evolved to keep
up with that sort of population growth
this is just another way of illustrating
this
at the time of uh jesus christ there
were 250 million people that's estimated
on the planet
took 1500 years to double that to 500
million it took homo sapiens about 120
000 years
to produce one billion people on the
planet
now it's taking us just a little around
a decade to add a billion
climate change this is going back um
400 000 years
so keeping it somewhere within the
confines of
our genus and its evolution
here's the temperature trace
co2
as we all know greenhouse gases
correlate with temperature
these ice ages are caused by actually uh
astronomical features earth orbital
changes earth tilt of the axis changes
that are pretty well understood at least
they're triggered by that
homo sapiens came back let's say around
here
oh it looks like some well that's pretty
rapid change let's look at this one
coming out of the last ice age into the
holocene the stable relatively stable
period rather that looks like a very
rapid change but keep in mind
you know this is ten thousand years it
took about twenty thousand years to rise
about eight degrees centigrade nine
degrees centigrade which is about point
0.1 degrees centigrade per 100 years
0.1 degrees centigrade for 100 years
keep that figure in your head when i
talk about what's projected for this
century
in my next slide i'm just going to show
a very recent period just going back
about you know 12 000 years
um the younger driest period from here
to here
and the holocene
so
about 11 000 years ago or so end of the
last glacial
we had a rise with the younger dryas of
about four and a half degrees centigrade
8.1 degrees over the course of a couple
thousand years
that too is less than something like
half a degree c per hundred years
the medieval warm period was a very
dramatic period in the medieval times
people began colonizing greenland and
farming there then came along the famous
little ice age so-called little ice age
it wasn't a real ice age
but that was a temperature drop of about
one degree c
again i'm showing you these numbers to
put in context of the climate change
that's projected for our century what
did that little ice age drop do
what were the impacts of that
communities were completely abandoned in
greenland iceland and northern europe
average male height declined across
northern europe
the pope ordered witch hunts
to figure out who was causing this
little ice age
that's what a one degree c drop can do
um here's that co2 and that graph i
showed you going back 400 000 years at
the top i had the co2 trace going back
and forth 400 000 years back and forth
between about 200 and 280 this is just
focusing on the co2 trace and this is
what's happened in very recent times
currently we're we've risen about 0.8
degrees c 1.4 degrees just enough since
the industrial revolution and of course
the spooky part is the the trajectory
we're on now in terms of co2
that's the business as usual scenario
here's if we really get our act together
and start slowing this down but look at
the magnitude of these even sort of a
best case scenario
uh compared to some of the magnitudes i
talked so do we think our minds have
really can really wrap around this i
think there's some challenges there
in case you're like you know feeling
sort of uh special thinking about how we
can impact the climate change now again
you know we're superior because only we
could do that to the climate
i suppose many of you in this room would
know who did that before us the
cyanobacteria the first photosynthetic
organisms
took our
about 2 billion years ago
invented photosynthesis which took up
co2 gives off oxygen
wiped out mass extinctions of anaerobic
uh species that lived on the planet when
multi-cellular plant life came on it
rose the oxygen level even further with
more photosynthesis so
we're not alone in being able to do that
um okay we're on our grand uh climate
change experiment
phase one is complete
completed in my career
i didn't expect it
despite clear floral warning and maybe
this is
you know my bias i thought we were clear
but maybe not
we did not have the mental capacity to
avoid a magnitude of climate change that
will negatively affect at least some
humans and other species
phase two is in progress
will we have the capacity to cope with
that is simply adapt
to some of the inevitable climate change
underway
how good is our intelligence our
capacity to work together etc phase
three is also in progress will we have
the capacity to prevent
mitigate
a truly catastrophic change in climate
what's a catastrophic change in climate
well
i mean some people think it's you know
it's all just going to be warmer and
better and it's not catastrophic at all
of course
others say it's a matter of degree and
there's certain things that could be
okay and nice and some that might not
let me just show you something from a
recent science that kind of spooks me a
bit
this is from a recent article by
different bond chris field in science
coming out actually in the most recent
intergovernmental panel climate change
studies
this puts into perspective what happens
uh if we burn up all the fossil fuels
that's what this graphic is really about
on here something
that should be familiar to you except
it's on again on even smaller scale this
is that co2 trace going back 800 000
years here up and back between 200 and
280 parts per million
thousands of years before the present
800 000 years here's the various
scenarios fossil fuel use scenarios that
we've talked about playing out this
century
possibly up to 800 parts per million or
so
and i gave you some numbers about what
that could mean five degrees six seven
degrees c rise in temperature
here's where we go if we burn up all the
fossil fuels
which has been estimated at 20 000 giga
tons
2 000 parts a million
i told at the beginning i've done a lot
of co2 research on plants and one thing
you know one sort of little silver
lining to some of the climate change
work has been that when plants are
exposed to higher co2 levels because
they take co2 for photosynthesis to grow
it can benefit some plant species but we
never went up to 2000 not very often and
in fact when you do the leaves curl they
get starch grains and the plants don't
do very well at all so that co2 level
even if there weren't a concomitant
climate change would
wreak havoc on a lot of plant life on
the planet
uh it's a imagine that this would uh
speculate this will diminish over time
due to photosynthetic uptake and some
other things
but that level
you've all probably read the information
about what even this level might mean
for sea level rise etc uh that could be
uh close to catastrophic not that there
won't be any humans left on the planet
but they're all going to be in the
highlands of ithaca new york
um
i just got this cartoon there for a
little break
um
bringing back uh i'd like to bring in
these you know powerful
big time thinkers here to support my
arguments
darwin it's not the strongest of the
species that survive nor the most
intelligent
that survives it is the one that is most
adaptable to change
he didn't put a lot of faith in
intelligence
can we successfully think our way
through our self-imposed environmental
challenges that's the question
i posed to you now i'll come up with a
couple
pieces of evidence looking
for
a way to leave you with some optimism
and now there are some i've you know
i've been
heavy on the negative
we have turned a corner on human
population growth rate i did not think
this would happen when i was young and
run airlift's population bomb
we have actually made some significant
changes
this is a recent science article
showing dramatic reductions in the
global fertility rate there's some
exceptions continental africa many
nations there still have fairly high
fertility rates this wasn't really
intentional it wasn't really um
you know in all cases something where
we've got we're reaching a maximum of
our resources sometimes it was
simply a focus on poverty or social
justice
gender issues
education of women as well as men
etc but
i think a real example of something to
be optimistic about i think in case of
china's official one-child policy it
wasn't yes that's that's exactly true i
would say it was that that's an
intentional example right
which has its own you know i mean might
have issues about that but it was
intentional um
ecological models now more clearly
recognize human societies as part of
natural systems ecologists are doing
this routinely uh this is something from
terry chapel and mathematics a climate
change model and very strong emphasis on
social systems in there i think that's a
very positive uh sign
we have begun to acknowledge and even
celebrate our kinship with other species
just a few months ago
india declared
dolphins non-human persons with
special rights
uh so several other countries have done
the same thing
it means you can't have them in
captivity you can't have them doing
tricks for you uh a variety of things
going on there
i think we're learning about a lot about
framing the discourse on climate change
i like this quote
know when we when we talk uh
particularly the people who
we're trying to bring into the issue not
people who are very familiar and ready
to go at it and start
fixing things
my opinion is
that
the best we can do especially as we're a
lot of nature lovers here in the natural
resources department
most of us are in a department like this
or affiliated with a department like
this because of our passion for the
natural world actually being i would say
almost in love with the natural world
i think sharing that
is probably the most productive thing we
can do in terms of at least getting
people on the right course rather than
talking to them about how polluted the
world is and how they they've got
something they've got to do to fix it
that can come later
but people don't want to destroy
that which they love and i think part of
what is so wonderful about the world is
actually our connection with other
species our similarities and not our
differences
on a more kind of concrete level
communications
researchers have done a lot on framing
the issues and they kind of come up with
some approaches
that i think were
discovered because they work
but actually from what i've talked about
in this seminar i think you can see
there's some
it relates to some of these evolutionary
constraints
communication now by emphasizing the
human and the local impacts not the
global impacts
and emphasizing practical solutions and
economically viable alternatives to the
path we're on
and to the extent we respond to local
while the local impacts are changing
mindsets here and there
when people have to pay the costs of
adapting
dealing with climate change even among
the farmers that i work closely with
the most recent and intensive and
comprehensive survey
in the midwest of um
something like six thousand
farmers
uh maybe it was forty i'm sorry 4 800
farmers
uh found that over 65 percent uh said
they quote believed in climate change
not all of them were convinced seeing
what were causing it
but majority felt that was human caused
there's a lot we can
see around us individuals local
communities governments corporations
attempt to make a difference for some of
my friends in the room i've got
solarized caroline there
walmart gets
a lot of um
you know
bad press and it's got some issues now
with pay rates for employees i know
and whether this is just green washing
or how deep it goes but just the just
the fact that they feel like they need
to do this
is i think a sign in the right direction
and of course the unipcc again i might
be biased because i've been affiliated
in various ways
um
you know i think that that's an example
of our social structures actually doing
a decent job
so isn't intelligence an adaptive trait
it will be up to us to demonstrate that
as so particularly the younger people in
the room
until then it's really not a fact
it's a it's a belief it's a faith and
it's a hope
and i'll leave you with this quote that
i like
if you look at the science about what is
happening on earth and aren't
pessimistic you don't understand data
but if you meet the people who are
working to restore this earth and the
lives of the poor and you aren't
optimistic you haven't got a pulse
i have some references here for those
who are interested but i think i'll just
leave it with that slide and
okay questions thanks
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu
you